All right.
Let's get started.
News from webperf-landia.
It's going to be a really
tough act to follow.
Impossible, I think.
Only [INAUDIBLE]
can do what he does.
I'm going to give you some
tips for some of the things
we've been working
on in the W3C webperf
group and related topics
about some of the techniques
that you can use to
optimize your plundering
around the web in particular.
There are four things
we're going to cover.
Some of them are
already available today.
Some of them are coming.
Some of them are actually
still in the works,
so we're looking for feedback,
use cases, and all the rest,
and that's where
you guys come in.
We're going to go in
order of these APIs.
The best one by far is the Bacon
API for faster bacon delivery,
and you'll see
exactly what I mean.
There's stuff like getting
connection type such
that you can optimize your apps.
You can figure out
if users are not
getting to your site,
which is something
that you can't
actually do today.
And then finally, we're going
to talk about some of the work
that I've been doing
recently with resource hits.
Let's start with the best
one, blocking loot beacons.
A very common pattern
on the web today
is you want to track what
happens when somebody clicks
or when somebody
performs an action.
In particular, that's
important for things
like let's say somebody's
clicking away from your site
or you're trying to
just log some activity.
A user clicks on
an activity and you
want to record the fact that
they're going to a checkout
or they want to buy something.
The common way you do that today
is, of course, because you're
navigating away from the page,
the page is getting unloaded.
You need to stop the
page from unloading.
You need to send a request
to your analytics server,
you need to wait
for that to finish.
If you're doing it right,
then I hope at least
you're setting a timeout.
You're saying, I'll wait for
200 milliseconds or something
like that, and then it
will resume and actually
let the navigation continue.
And of course, that is a
terrible performance pattern.
It's an anti-pattern,
in fact, because we're
blocking actual navigation
from proceeding because we
need to log the
actual analytics.
That is why we have Beacon now.
This is a new thing that
is now available in Firefox
and Chrome, and
using this API, you
can actually post data
to a URL asynchronously.
What this means is that
you no longer have to wait,
and you can get on with
navigating to the new page,
and the browser will take
care of actually delivering
the payload that you give it.
It's actually really
nice because it's
much more flexible than
when you could do before,
and it actually allows the
browser to do better delivery,
so we can do things like
retries and other things
on your behalf.
All of this is already handled.
This is actually very similar
if you've seen a ping.
This is an attribute
that you can actually
put on a link that
says, for example,
please navigate to
the site, but when
the user clicks on this
thing, please also send
a ping registering the fact that
somebody has clicked on this.
This is not supported
across all browsers,
but Chrome supports
it, Safari supports it,
and it actually is fairly
well established on mobile.
For example, Google
search last year
deployed this on all
mobile search results,
where before you
were actually getting
redirected to a redirect service
which would then send a 301.
That's an unnecessary
redirect, and they
needed that because they need
to register the fact that you've
clicked on the link.
This helped us improve search
quality and all the rest.
Nowadays, they don't do that.
Instead, they use
the ping attribute,
which allows them to basically
send two requests at once.
One navigates to the
actual destination, one
logs the fact that a
click has happened.
This helps you
optimize performance.
This works today.
This is great, but it's
limited in the sense
that you can't actually
post arbitrary data.
You can encode some
data in the URI itself,
but that's fairly limited in
terms of the amount of data
you can push and what kind of
data you can push in there.
In effect, Beacon is an
improved version of a ping.
It's supported on both
Firefox and Chrome today.
One nice thing is
that it actually
allows you to send up
to 64 kilobytes of data,
and this is arbitrary data.
You can stuff a JSON payload
or whatever other data type
you want, and we will
take care of just posting
that data to the server.
It's available today
and you can use it.
And best part, Google
Analytics has actually
just recently
rolled out support,
and you can actually enable
this on Google Analytics.
You do need to modify
your code a little bit.
You need to pass this additional
flag that says Use Beacon True.
Because this is
still a new API, we
have not enabled it by default.
I'm hoping that in
the future, we'll
just make that the default. and
you can opt out if you want to,
and we'll detect the fact that
maybe a particular browser
doesn't support it.
But this is by far a much
better way to deliver Beacon.
So for example, if you're
using Google Analytics
and you're using things
like click tracking,
today, they would
actually tell you
to inject additional JavaScript
code and all the rest
and pause your navigations to
log analytics and all the rest.
You can avoid all of that
and get your bacon faster.
This is very important
because actually, this
is how all of the ads
monetization and everything
else works.
Clicks matter.
One of the goals here
was to make it simple,
make it fast, and also improve
the reliability of delivery
of these beacons.
A ping has actually
had some bad rap
in the past on the
browsers that support it
in terms of the
actual delivery rate.
It just hasn't
been that reliable.
With Beacon, we're actually
taking a clean slate approach
and we're making sure that
that is very well handled,
and we're seeing very
good results there,
so definitely something
that you want to check out.
Use it today, available today.
Awesome.
Next, we have Forecasting
Network Weather.
Sometimes it's
actually very useful
to know what type of connection
is a user currently on.
For example, are they
on a cellular connection
or are they on Wi-Fi?
Or god forbid, maybe they're
using Bluetooth tethering
or Bluetooth to
access the internet.
It's also useful to know more
detailed data for things like,
how fast is the link
that they're on?
So the fact that I told you
that the user's on cellular
is not very useful by
itself because there's
a lot of variety there.
There's 2G, there's
3G, there's LTE,
LTE advanced, and all
these kinds of things.
We're now exposing
two attributes,
and downlinkMax is actually
really, really fresh.
This is something
that we've just
recently added to the spec.
Let's look at the
actual logic here.
First of all, let's
talk about the use case.
This is a recent headline
where Facebook is actually
using bandwidth targeting to
deliver a different experience.
In this particular case,
this is for advertising.
They detect the
fact that you used
happen to be on a
slower connection,
so it doesn't make
sense for me to try
to jam a video ad into this
pipe because you're not
going to even see it, frankly.
It's going to take you 10
seconds to download it,
so that's a bad experience.
That's one use case
of how you could
use this sort of information.
Note that we're not
saying here that this
is the actual download
speed of the client.
We're just saying this is
the maximum potential speed
that you could get.
All we know is the last hop.
Similarly, you can actually
use a lot of this data
to do analytics.
I've actually talked to a number
of companies that are currently
segmenting their conversion
data on connection type,
and they're finding different
performance for things
like, hey, we're getting a
lot more conversions on 4G
versus 3G and all the rest.
That is actually a
good signal to tell you
that there's maybe
performance problems on 3G
that we need to optimize
to up the conversion
rates and all the rest.
Analytics, customizing what you
deliver, what types of assets
you deliver.
Maybe you want to
pick a lower res image
or skip the video and
other things like that.
DownlinkMax is a new
attribute that we're adding,
and what it reports is the
actual megabits per second
of the last hop link.
This is very important.
What we're not
telling you is, what
is the expected or the
current bandwidth of the user?
Because frankly, that
is a very hard problem.
It's a very transient
thing, especially
on a cellular network where
these things go up and down all
the time.
Instead, we're
just saying, look,
we know that the user is
connected to an LTE network.
That's all we know.
On an LTE network,
regardless of what carrier
you're signed up with, the
maximum theoretical speed
as a written in the spec happens
to be 100 megabits per second.
When you query that value and
it says 100 megabits per second,
that's not to say
that I'm just going
to dump the 4K video
ad on the user.
That's not what we're saying.
We're just saying this is
the potential, the maximum.
This, of course, becomes very
useful for the lower range
of the pipe where
you start looking
at 2G connections, which are
still very much prevalent.
Believe it or not, I'm
sure you've all seen it.
We get bumped down to 2G
even around here every once
in a while.
You go to a big
event, you're on 2G.
This is where you can actually
use this sort of logic
to say, hey, I'm
currently on 2G.
I'm going to fetch maybe
a different set of assets
or I'm going to
do something else,
optimize my experience
for the user.
Now, there's another
important digression here.
Carriers have pulled
a fast one on us.
Well, it's not just
carriers, but they still
pulled a fast one on us.
We love to talk about
megabits per second.
Megabits and megabytes
are very different things.
Sorry?
Eight times different, exactly.
So the next time
you're hearing, I
did a bandwidth test and
my phone is really fast.
I'm getting 10
megabits per second,
and I'm downloading
a one megabyte image.
If you actually do
the math, let's say
you have a 10 megabit per second
connection, which is actually
really, really good, that's
about 1.2 megabytes per second.
So if you had a one megabyte
image, which is actually not
crazy with our super awesome
double retina something
advanced super screens--
double retina, exactly.
Retina HD.
That's the word.
It will still take a second
to download that image.
And more likely,
you're experiencing
much, much slower speeds.
So you have something like two
or three megabits per second,
and it will take four seconds.
This is an important
digression, but I
think it's something you
need to keep in mind.
Megabits and megabytes,
don't confuse those things.
The spec actually
reports it in megabits
because that's how
the industry works.
That's net info, and net
info is available currently
in Chrome and Firefox.
We're currently implementing
the max bandwidth stuff.
Hopefully in the next stable
release, that'll make it there.
Today, you can ready
query for type.
Next one is what I'm calling
sea monster detection.
So there's actually
a subtle problem
that we have today on the web,
which is if the user can't even
reach your site.
For example, before
we can log the fact
that somebody has
visited your site,
first we need to
find the IP address,
resolve the IP
address, take the name
and find the IP address of that.
Then we need to perform
the TCP handshake and all
that other stuff, and then we
can only send the HTTP request.
There's a bunch of
steps in here that
are basically invisible
to us as web developers,
and it's actually not
uncommon for users
to fail somewhere in there.
So you send your UDP
packet and it gets lost
and you have no idea
because the visitor never
made it to your site.
The DNS timed out.
Maybe you experienced DNS
problems or your server's
overloaded and the visitor
can't even reach your site
or establish the connection
with your HTTP server.
Those things just go
unreported unless you actually
have some users telling you that
through a side channel saying,
hey, I can't resolve your
DNS, and this is a problem.
For that, we actually have
navigation error logging API,
which is currently in the works.
There's no
implementation of it yet,
but I think we
actually finally have
the spec nailed down,
or very close to.
Expect this to come soon.
How does this work?
One way it could work is when
the user comes to your site,
they can actually
call window.performan
ce.getNavigationErrors and just
iterate through past errors.
If the user has had problems
accessing your site,
this would actually
contain a full log of,
hey, I tried to open your
site on Friday at 5:00 PM
and I experienced a TCP
something problem and this
is how long it took for
this thing to time out.
Of course, you can
use that information
to then log into
your back end and do
all the analytics you want.
But I think we can agree
that that's after the fact,
perhaps not as useful.
Still nice to have,
but not as useful.
What we also support
is this method
called enable navigation
error reporting, which
does live reporting.
So first, you have
to come to the site,
obviously, at least once, where
you would invoke this code
and it basically
says, hey, this site
would like to register for
error reporting moving forward.
Next time, if the user
experiences an issue,
we will actually pull up
that URL that you told us,
and when the timeout happens
or when the connection fails,
we will just beacon that
information directly
to that endpoint.
And of course, this is
the important part here.
You should beacon
to somewhere else
because if I can't connect
to your awesomething.com
and I'm trying to beacon
to awesomething.com,
that's not going to work.
You want to have a third party
service or some other domain
that is separate where you
would send these reports.
This way, you can actually
get real time reporting
of there's DNS
timeouts, or maybe I'm
getting blocked somewhere, or
TCP connections are failing,
and all the rest.
This is very, very cool
because today, in order
to get this sort of
data, you basically
need to control the client
and the actual site as well,
and only the largest
companies can do that today,
and it's very hard.
This will be really
awesome for just
improving your reliability.
And then finally, we're getting
to just faster navigations.
There's a bag of tricks here
that we want to talk about.
This is some data
that I just pulled up
from my own browsing session.
I'll show you guys
some examples later,
but if you go to
Chrome Histogram,
anybody been to Chrome
Histogram before?
Open a new tab and just
go to Chrome Histogram.
It has a very long page of
all the different metrics
of everything that
happens in your system,
and it's just histograms
of everything.
Just type in "TCP," and
you'll get 15 charts.
What I looked up
in there is, what
is my median DNS
resolution time?
What is my median
TCP handshake time?
What is my median TLS handshake
time, and all the rest?
By the way, this is
based on 10,000 samples,
and this is based on
the last day of me just
using my computer on this Wi-Fi.
You'd expect this Wi-Fi
to be pretty fast.
We do a pretty good
job of it Google,
but nonetheless, you
can see that things
like DNS handshakes, TCP
handshakes and all the rest--
or DNS lookups, rather--
take quite a bit of time,
60 milliseconds,
35 milliseconds.
If I add all of this up, for
a typical page, a median page,
it takes about 200 milliseconds
for me just to establish,
perform all the ceremony
before I can actually
even send HTTP request.
If you substitute numbers
for things like 3G or 4G,
this very quickly adds up
to one second of latency.
There is a lot of
latency that is just
spent on the initial
setup and the ceremony.
Browsers do a lot of stuff
to try and hide this.
We have things like, hey,
let's try and preresolve
all the links so
when we open a page
and there's a bunch
of links, let's just
look up all the DNS names, or
at least some of the DNS names
such that when you click on that
link, we don't have to wait.
Let's preconnect.
So before you even
click on a link
or as you start to hover towards
the link, it'll just say,
hey, it looks like
you're going there.
Let's start to preconnect,
because between the time
that you actually get to
the link and click, that's
a couple hundred milliseconds,
and a couple hundred
milliseconds counts
because by that time
we could have established
the connection
and we can send HTTP
request immediately.
That's pretty sweet.
And then there's things
like prefetch and prerender,
where we can actually
just say, look,
I think this user is likely
heading in that direction
or to that page next, so
let's prefetch the resource,
or let's just prerender
the entire page.
We'll just literally create
a hidden tab in your browser,
we'll prerender the page,
and when you actually
say, yes, I want to go there,
we'll just swap it out.
It loads instantly, but
we're just really swapping
behind the scenes
the actual render.
These are tricks that
are available across most
of the browsers today.
In Chrome, you can actually
inspect all of the stuff.
If you go to something
like Chrome DNS
and once again open a new
tab, Chrome Predictors,
and Chrome Histograms.
Between these three,
you can actually
see all the different things
that we're doing under the hood
and trying to predict
and all the rest.
Chrome actually
learns quite a bit
about your browsing patterns.
Over time as you use
it more and more,
we actually observe things
like, what are the first 10
tabs that you open in the
morning when you open Chrome?
We'll remember that, and
next time you open it,
we'll just preconnect to all
of those sites immediately.
Yes, you're going
to check the news,
you're going to open
Gmail, and something else.
These small tricks do a lot
to improve user experience,
and the interesting
observation here
is that the browser does
a pretty good job of this,
but site developers,
you guys, have
a lot of knowledge about
your own applications.
Let's say we're looking at a
sports app or a sports section,
and if you know that the user
always navigates to the NBA
section and then clicks
on whatever team,
that's just what
they do each morning,
or whenever a user expands
a particular section,
then they go to something else.
You know these things
that the browser doesn't.
What we really need to
do is provide you access
to the same primitives such
that you can hint the browser
to say, hey, I think
the user's going
to do this next, so
start doing your stuff.
That's what these
resource hints are.
We have three, preconnect,
preload, and prerender.
The quick anatomy of this thing
is basically, this is a hint.
It's a link element where
you put a resource name.
We'll talk about
the rel, which is
the preconnect,
preload, or prerender.
That's the type of a hint.
There is the as, which
describes the type of the asset
that we're talking about.
This is basically like,
I want you to fetch this
as if it was a
style sheet, or as
if it's an image
or something else.
This just allows
us to prioritize
the fetches better
in the browser.
Then there is need the actual
link, and of course media
queries.
So you can say, look,
this hint is only relevant
if I'm on mobile and
my screen is thus big,
or it's only relevant for high
DPI screens and all the rest.
That's as expected.
And probabilities,
we'll talk about that.
Let's look at the simplest one
and the first one, preconnect.
It basically just
says, look, there's
a lot of latency that is spent
just doing the DNS, the TCP,
and the TLS because
increasingly, we
need to just secure
all the things.
What we can do here
is we can say, look,
I think I'm going to be fetching
resources from the server.
I'm not yet sure what resources
exactly I'm going to fetch.
For example, you have
some dynamic thing
that you need to
fetch, like I know
I'm going to have to
connect to an ad server
and request some ads.
I'm not sure what they are
yet, so just start doing
that now, and by the
time you're done,
I'll probably know the
actual URL and everything
will be much better.
But then you can also say, look,
sometimes I'm not quite sure.
I may need to connect to
this thing, but maybe not,
and that's why we
have probability.
Probability allows you to
express some sort of notion of,
I may or may not
need this thing.
You'll see why this becomes
more relevant for some
of the other hints.
This is one of
those things where
you can be anticipating
user behavior.
You could say, well, if a
user expands the NBA section,
I will need to connect
to these five things
to fetch the other
images, and I think
the probability of
the user actually
doing that is about 0.75,
something like that.
So if you tell us that
the probability is one,
it basically means it's a
required hint and the user
agent must execute it,
whereas everything else is up
for grabs.
The observation
here is that these
are speculative optimizations
that could, in fact, request
extra resources
which may go unused.
If you're really,
really aggressive
with all your prefetching
and all the rest,
you're going to fetch a lot
of data that you'll never use.
That's also not good because
you've consumed a user's data
plan, battery, and all the rest.
So as an example,
let's say two hints.
We have a preconnect with 1.0
and a preconnect with 0.4.
Depending on how the
user agent is currently,
or how the device is doing
currently, it will say,
great, I've got full battery,
I happen to be on Wi-Fi,
I've got a ton of resources.
I'm just going to
follow this whole thing.
And in fact, for 1.0, that's
pretty much guaranteed.
But for a low probability
hint, something like 0.4,
like you may or may
not use this and I
happen to be running
low on battery,
maybe I'll skip the hint
entirely, but for this case,
maybe I'll just do the DNS
preconnect, or the preresolve,
rather.
So the user agent reserves the
right to shift some of the work
and figure out what is
the optimal strategy
to improve the user
experience here.
Next, we get to preload.
This is kind of interesting.
This is basically a
declarative way of saying,
I need this resource.
Preconnect was just
a way for you to say,
I need to connect
to that server,
and that's important because
it just takes a long time.
For preload, think
of this as XHR kind
of, but in a declarative way.
What you're saying
here is, look,
I will need this
critical CSS file.
Please fetch it as if
it's a style sheet.
I will definitely need it.
Only fetch it if the screen
matches this media query,
or if this media query
is matched, rather.
The difference here
between fetching this
as a regular style sheet is that
it's actually not processed.
This is just downloading.
Please just download this.
Don't parse the CSS.
Don't execute.
Don't apply it to
the current page.
I will tell you later when
I want this to be applied.
This is really cool because
today, whenever you include
a link rel style
sheet, we actually
block rendering on that because
that's just how CSS works.
Now, you can actually
decouple these two things
and say, download
this now and later,
I will inject it into
my dom and all the rest,
and you can apply it and
do all the other things
that you need to do.
This is really, really
useful, and it will solve,
I think, a lot of
problems for us.
And then finally,
we have prerender.
So preload is something that
you would use to fetch resources
declaratively for the
current page, things
like critical assets, additional
assets, and all the rest,
and prerender is something that
you can use for the next page.
You can say, look, I
think the user's heading
in that direction next,
and on that next page,
I will need DCSS
files, these images.
Maybe it's a big product image
that you want to prerender such
that it is played
very, very quickly.
Perhaps the biggest
difference here
is when the user
starts navigating
towards the new destination,
we don't cancel those requests.
Today, if you think
about it, if you initiate
a bunch of XHR requests and
then the user clicks away,
we will actually
cancel all of those.
That's just how
the process works
because we don't want to persist
those requests because you're
navigating away from the
page, so cancel all the things
and let's move on
to the next page.
Prerender, this
is a hint to say,
I think I will need this
on the next rendered page,
so please don't cancel
these things and let them
continue, and then the next
page can make use of them.
This way, you can actually
use a similar strategy
as I described before.
As the user's heading towards
that link, you could say,
I know where they're heading.
I will need these
five resources,
so start fetching
those now, and then
the next page can be
rendered much faster.
So here's a quick overview
of how this actually works
and where you would use it.
We have Fetch Start
here at the top.
This is where we just
start fetching the page,
and you can inject
a bunch of hints
right at the
beginning of the page
to say, look, I will need to
preconnect to these servers,
I will need to prefetch
these resources.
Do all that for me.
This is a way for you to help
optimize the initial render.
Once the page is rendered, you
have all of your regular tools.
You have the XHR, the images,
the scripts, and all the rest.
None of that has changed.
Everything's the same.
Then finally, there is
another transition here,
which is the user's
navigating away
or towards a new destination.
You can say, look,
this is great.
This is where you use
prerender because you inject
the prerender hints
on the current page
but they will be used
on the next page.
That's the only
distinction, really,
the important distinction
between preload and prerender.
This is a working, living doc.
There's a lot of examples.
The spec is something
that we've been working on
in the webperf group for
a couple of months now.
Please check it out on GitHub.
There's a lot of
examples in there.
I would love to
get your feedback
in terms of what are the other
use cases that perhaps are
missing, that we're not
covering, and all the rest.
Take a read through.
I tried to put as many
examples in there as I could.
This is a quick summary.
If you're not familiar
with these APIs,
just follow these links.
I'll share the slides.
You don't need to copy that
because you can actually
find the slides at
pirateperf and perfmatters.
All right.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]